In this lesson, we will shift our attention to public and population health.
Unlike the clinical setting,
where the focus is traditionally on
individual patients after they become sick or injured,
public and population health focus on groups of patients or the public at large.
These can be as small as
a local neighborhood or as big as an entire country or region of the world.
We will begin this lesson with the discussion of
public health and then discuss population health.
In a landmark report,
the Institute of Medicine define public health as,
"What we as a society do collectively to
assure the conditions in which people can be healthy."
Note the emphasis on collective action.
This is a recognition that complex social factors have a powerful influence on
our health and that we require
disparate data sources to understand
the impact of many determinants of health and disease.
Also keep in mind that the World Health Organization,
a globally recognized public health organization defines health as,
"The state of complete physical, mental,
and social well-being and not merely the absence of disease or infirmity."
From an informatics perspective,
many aspects of public health are similar to population health in that both aggregate,
analyze, and report on data as shown here.
Public health takes a broad view of the factors that influence health,
where you live and work,
the social norms of your culture,
the types of health care you have access to,
your exposure to diseases and stressors in your environment,
among other influences, to create this broad view.
Public health uses disparate data sources to
fulfill its core functions and essential services.
Traditional health care is oriented around treating disease.
Once that occurs, public health professionals try
to detect and prevent problems from happening or recurring.
The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention, CDC,
is the federal agency charged with protecting and improving public health,
but it generally does not collect surveillance information directly.
Rather, the US public health surveillance system relies on
established partnerships with more than 3,000 local agencies.
CDC works through these agencies to collect,
analyze and share data that address
the many factors and determinants of health and disease.
Since the key mission in public health is data aggregation and reporting,
inter-operability is obviously of great importance.
This is particularly true here in the US,
given the large number of reporting agencies in this country.
Globally, ministries of health are
the key agencies responsible for tracking cases of human illness.
Other important partners are community organizations,
the health care delivery systems,
schools, businesses, the transportation sector,
the media and other government agencies.
Data from public health surveillance
inform policies and direct decisions about resources for
services that promote healthy lifestyles and control the spread of infectious diseases.
Another major aspect of public health is promoting health care,
equity, quality, and accessibility.
Given the importance of inter-operability,
FIHR could potentially facilitate data aggregation and as we will see in what follows.
Public health experts increasingly see FIHR as an important health informatics tool.
CDC describes its mission as protecting America from
health safety and security threats wherever they originate.
We will now learn more about the CDC and
its mission and how informatics plays a key role in public health.